[Music]
happy sabbath everyone and happy sabbath
elder skeet have you said with my
handsome brother god bless you
you're handsome as well god created oh
thank you thank you i'm surprised thanks
all right so we have a third question
that's actually taken from revelation
chapter 14 verse 5 and i'll read it
first it says in their mouth was found
no guile
and also it says for they are without
fault before the throne of god right
revelation 14 verse 5 tells us that the
000 are found without fault before the
throne of god by what means are they
without fault and did they ever sin
of course they sinned the only person
who never sinned is jesus christ of
course they sin but they conquered sin
the sacrifice of christ which includes
his life his very difficult life his
death this resurrection all of that must
be regarded as a sacrifice of christ the
atonement of christ all of that
provides the power for us to live above
sin we can conquer sin we see i can do
all things through christ the power to
conquer sin is in christ's atonement we
sometimes refer to as his blood
that is the power and so we are required
to come to sin if you study the seven
letters to the seven churches of
revelation chapters two and three
each one is told to overcome even the
two churches that receive no rebuke
smyrna church number two and
philadelphia church number six they
receive no rebuke from christ yet
they're told he that overcometh shall
not be heard of the second death as as
christ told the second year smyrna and
so overcoming overcoming revelation 3 21
to him that overcometh will i grant to
sit with me in my throne even as i also
overcame we must overcome sin the way
christ was victorious yes they have
overcome sin but they have not lived
sinless lives only christ did that but
we have available to us through the
living christ the power to conquer sin
and those persons have conquered saying
and that the final generation on this
earth when jesus christ comes will have
conquered sin so that christ can present
them or god the father can present them
to the universe
to finally disprove the charge of satan
that god's law cannot be perfectly kept
jesus did it but he was only one witness
and the jewish tradition says you need
two or three witnesses the final
generation those who conquer sin in the
power of christ will be the second
witness god needs here is christ and
here those who live a christ-like life
and so that group in revelation 14 5
they have conquered sin through christ
and that challenge is for us
everyone who comes to christ that
person's aim must be christ's likeness
total conquest of sin because one sin
unattended will destroy you
the smallest sin
the least
so-called significant bad habit will
destroy a person if it is not dealt with
one sinful admired garden one sin can
ruin things in heaven and so conquest of
sin is absolutely necessary and there
will be those alive on the earth who
have conquered sin through christ they
overcame him by the blood of the lamb
and by the word of the testimony
revelation 12 11. you have conquered
sin amen amen and one of the
connect on to that is also in jude 1 24
it says now
that is able to keep you from falling to
present you faultless
before the presence of his glory with
exceeding joy absolutely yes
it must be a personal desire of ours
it does not happen by osmosis it must be
a person you know jesus said blessed are
they which do hunger and thirst after
righteousness righteousness is the
opposite of sin
and so we must hunger and thirst for
this character of christ which is
flawless righteousness
it is possible through him
because it is he living out that life in
us amen amen
[Music]